hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host john
carroll
long-time listeners will know that there
are two things i'm really interested in
one is entropy i mean there's more than
two things i like to think but anyway
two of them
entropy the arrow of time right how
entropy increases
over time in the language of statistical
mechanics and
why that draws a distinction between the
past and the future
and then separately but in a related
sense life
the idea of biological life the origin
of life the evolution of life
so it's very natural and we've done it
before to bring these two things
together because living systems
are physical systems they obey the laws
of physics and so it's
they're out of equilibrium systems
they're systems that are open and
interact with their environment
and they take part in they participate
in the overall
increase of entropy in the universe so
today's guest is one of the world's
leaders in thinking about this
intersection
of statistical mechanics and entropy
with life
both its origin and its evolution and
its functioning on a day-to-day basis
jeremy england is well known especially
to readers of quantum magazine
uh qanta which is one of my favorite
science magazines has uh profiled jeremy
and talked about his work a lot
what he's doing is taking modern
advances
in non-equilibrium statistical mechanics
that is to say not just the simple fact
that entropy increases but the ways in
which it increases and the fluctuations
around
the overall tendency to increase and
applies them to
what life is how it operates how it
originated
but there's a twist to this story i mean
jeremy will be very obvious mindscape
guest but the twist is the following
jeremy is also an ordained rabbi in the
orthodox jewish tradition
and in his new book called every life is
on fire how thermodynamics explains the
origins of living things
jeremy does not shy away from talking
about the relationship in his mind
between his jewish faith and the words
that he reads in the hebrew bible
and his ideas about physics and biology
so i thought this would be a fun thing
to talk about obviously very different
perspective than what i usually have
it's just a
fun weird conversation because when
we're talking about physics and
uh biology uh we're very very much on
the same wavelength more than most
physicists or biologists but then
he was really into reading the hebrew
bible in a way that i'm i'm really not
into that so
it's a very nice way to learn um from
someone who is a very smart person
thinking about things in a very
different way so you may agree or
disagree with any part
of the podcast but i hope that it gives
you something to think about
that's why we're here so let's go
jeremy england welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you very much
so we share a weird kind of
quasi-notoriety i was slightly uh
perplexed and um i guess tickled but
also weirded out to see
the name of my book the big picture
appear in dan brown's
novel called origin but then
you did way better than i did because
you're a character in that book
indeed indeed yes that was a surprising
moment for me i guess was it it was
three
years ago and a few months that i found
out it was happening and then the book
came out i think almost exactly three
years ago
um so that was a peculiar time uh an
unexpected one
you had no idea right i mean he didn't
talk to you and you weren't yeah no
he asked me um to have lunch with him a
month before the book came out and i
didn't know why i speculated maybe he
was starting to write a book and he was
talking to scientists to try to
get ideas and um he
told me the book was about to come out
and i said oh that's interesting and
um so yeah uh that that was uh
one of the more surprising things that
happened to me so far
in my scientific career well look in
some sense it's not surprising i mean
you're thinking about ideas that uh
bring in together
notions from physics and biology and the
origin and nature of life
big picture kind of ideas and it's kind
of uh catnip for a novelist who wants to
juice up their story with some some
profound consequences but you weren't
you weren't happy
with how you were portrayed as i recall
yeah well i
i think that um it's it's not an
irrelevant
subject for the discussion of my own
book that we're having now
because while on the one hand obviously
the research that i was doing before
ever having any involvement
in fictional pieces written by dan brown
was something
i already was interested in and
motivated to pursue and
excited by and well also
thinking about broader questions about
uh what other languages there are with
which we can talk about the boundary
between life and non-life and
how the human experience as a whole is
impacted by how we view life and think
about what it is
while i was also already quite
interested in that i think
i didn't really have the same kind of
fire lit under me to try to combine both
discussions in one book
until dan brown helped me to become so
aware
of how much potential for public
reaction beyond the scope of the science
there is
when you start putting ideas like this
out there and i think especially being
portrayed as someone who wasn't
interested in the broader discussion
really made me feel like no i really am
interested in the broader discussion so
maybe i should just make sure to go on
record uh at length
to that effect yeah it's actually a
really good point i hadn't thought about
it in those terms but you're right
because
i know that you know as a when i give
talks on cosmology
um i learned this from martin reese a
world famous theoretical astrophysicist
he gave a popular level talk on
cosmology
and in the middle of it he started
talking about life on other planets
and i'm sitting there in the audience as
a cosmologist i'm thinking wait a minute
that's not cosmology why are you talking
about that kind of stuff but
we forget that the you know people out
there who are interested in these things
don't draw these strict boundaries
in the same way that we do and it's
actually useful to try to
step outside and make these connections
that we're not supposed to be making in
our professional lives
yeah and i think especially the question
of how life might have come into being
when talked about in the language of
physics or or looking at
uh the universe in a forensic way and
trying to cast a glance backward
once you're engaging in that discussion
i think there's no question that
there are people who line up along
either side
of what they view as a line of scrimmage
between
the natural sciences and biblical
religion and they're looking for
a winner take all outcome and and so
i didn't want to pretend to be naive and
sort of say oh well i'm just you know
sharing some thoughts for for people's
uh delegation because i think it's it's
too clear that
if you come out and say okay i think we
understand something more about
where lifelike behavior comes from in
physical terms there are people who are
going to and really who already have
take that and say this is the last stake
in the heart of believing anything the
bible has to say
and you know at the end of the day i i'm
coming from a personal place as well
i in adulthood after kind of growing up
as
a theoretical physicist uh decided that
being was a jew important sorry being i
decided that being a jew was important
enough to me
uh to invest a lot more effort in
studying the torah
and the rest of the hebrew bible and my
tradition
and i've been quite gratified at the
intellectual depth
that i find there in engagement with
these questions um
so i don't myself see the contradictions
or the
the throw down winner take all kind of
fight that i referred to
there i don't see it as being necessary
but i'm conscious of how
readily that pops up and i i do think
it's an
important kind of uh
additional discussion to attach to this
just to kind of make sure i'm not
uh putting stuff out there that will get
essentially used to push in a direction
that i
myself am not particularly interested in
pushing yeah and i think
it's a very important discussion have
we'll definitely get there but even
before
getting there there's a whole nother
line of scrimmage which is between
biology and physics
right even before you bring in the third
uh corner of the
hat so so why don't we start there to
lay some groundwork and and you know on
the podcast we've talked about
these things before we've talked about
the origin of life and and things like
that but
everyone has a slightly different take
on this why don't you tell me
what you have in mind when you talk
about the origin the nature the process
that we called life
sure so i think this is something i try
to treat
uh somewhat carefully uh in the book
i think that when starting this
discussion the most important first
thing is to realize that
you can be talking about the world as a
scientist and actually
there are different languages you could
choose to use and i think we sometimes
miss that because we think
of science as this monolith and we just
sort of want to say what does science
say about this
but within science just the difference
between looking at the world as a
physicist or looking at the world as a
biologist
you have different categories and
different vocabularies and different
criteria that you take for granted in
how you
make sense of the same phenomenon so i
could
talk about the world as a physicist and
then if i'm going to do that i'm going
to start by
trying to be very basic and say let me
say what numbers can i get out of making
certain basic measurements i can measure
distance i can measure time
i can quantify an amount of substance
etc and then you build up this whole
framework for how do i predict these
numbers from those numbers
and it's an inherently quantitative
enterprise biology by contrast
i would argue is not inherently
quantitative in the same way
in present day biology there's a huge
amount of quantification that goes on
and it's very useful for addressing
certain kinds of questions
but if you go back to the beginning the
idea of what is alive is something taken
for granted at the outset in biology you
say there's this
group of things in the world that are
alive like clams and people and trees
etc
so now let's try to make a science out
of what keeps them alive or stops them
from being alive
and that can be begun at least in
qualitative terms you can find out that
when you
cut off a chicken's head it always dies
and there's not really
a numerical analysis that needs to be
done there in order for that to become
very good empirical science and that's i
think fundamentally fundamentally
different from physics you can't
get physics going without starting to
talk about the world
in terms of numbers that you make out of
it and and by the way
in terms of numbers that are priori
don't see the difference between life
and non-life you know you look at a
table or you look at
a frog and if you're being really
fundamental in your physical description
you just say well in both cases
i have a bunch of molecules or i have a
bunch of particles atoms i have a bunch
of quantum fields however you know
whatever frame you're putting on it
the difference between those two objects
is you know sort of a different initial
condition or a different assembly state
of similar materials
and it's not something where the physics
draws a bright line for you in a
qualitative sense
so just the fact that you come to the
world and the same phenomenon in the
world and say
okay if i toss a cat off a tower because
physicists always like endangering cats
and their thought experiments
if i toss a cat off a tower i can ask
how fast is it moving when it hits the
ground and that's a physical question
or i could ask whether it's alive
afterwards and that's a biological
question
and even if there's some translation i
can make between these two conceptual
frames
it's never going to be the same thing to
ask if something is alive as it is to
ask how fast it's moving
and we need to recognize our own role in
engaging in that work of translation
well you're suggesting or you're sort of
hinting at a whole bunch of
discussions people have had about
reductionism and emergence and things
like that again things that we've talked
about before
on the podcast uh i mean i've always
thought that the reductionism versus
emergence
debate to the extent that it was a
debate was kind of boring
in the sense that i'm an in-principle
reductionist like if i knew the standard
model of particle physics and einstein's
general relativity in principle i could
do everything but
obviously in practice i can't do those
things and it seems like there's a camp
that says yes but in principle i could
and there's another camp that says yes
but in practice i can't and i'm not
quite sure why they're just not agreeing
with
each other do you do you see any actual
disagreement that we should that we
should care about here
well i i think that
i mean this is something i try to take
up early on in the book
and i i don't think that the point of
emergence
versus reductionism is irrelevant to the
discussion of
um let's say the boundary between life
and non-life and viewed in physical
terms
but i wouldn't want to conflate it with
the more kind of linguistic point about
talking about things
in biological terms versus physical
terms okay i i do
think that when talking about what
languages
are there are just some advantages that
one language has
over talking about the same phenomenon
as another so
while it might be feasible in principle
to describe what is going on in a stock
market
using a molecular dynamics simulation of
all the particles that all the people in
the whole economy that's involved in
everything are made of
it's an extremely unwieldy way of trying
to describe that and
you you put before you a huge stumbling
block
in trying to make the translations that
are necessary
whereas in this other language that we
have for talking about the world
that economics is born out of the
vocabulary
is naturally suited and even aimed at
that discussion and i think similarly
that works with biology as well so
while on the one hand sometimes
translating gets you new insight
because there was something about the
relationship between things in the
biological
space of concepts that you couldn't
really give a mechanistic explanation
for without resorting
to some kind of physical representation
of each of those
it's nonetheless the case that you
actually are interested in something
called
successful cell division or something
called
dna damage repair or these things where
high level
concepts in language are are going to be
expressed more effectively if we're not
talking about
particle 1 being at this position in
particle 2 being in that position
so i i don't think it's it's merely just
an issue of
uh the difference between reductionism
and emergence
i think it's also about kind of the the
appropriateness of different languages
and that
we're not going to be as successful in
describing the world
if we don't make languages that are
appropriate to the task and recognize
their
limitations and their advantages that
being said
i also think you know we're talking
about reductionism and and
uh emergence that's clearly relevant to
the discussion with biology
viewed through the lens of physics
because life
is a portion of the world that you kind
of want to draw a box around and say
can i explain what this thing is as a
phenomenon
in the same way that i can explain the
transition from a liquid to a solid
or the same way that i can explain uh
some more exotic
kind of uh behavior of
a collective of particles that you see
in i don't know fractional quantum hall
effects or whatever there are these
things that physics has been very good
at making sense of
where they see emergent predictability
and describability coming at a different
scale
than the microscopic description of the
individual degrees of freedom out of
which it seems like
the phenomenon gets going and clearly
life
has the potential to be addressed in
that way at least in principle
the thing that i would point to as a
difference though
is that life is a much more multifarious
semantic bundle
than the physical phenomena that we
typically refer to when we talk about
classic examples of emergence
so as an example if i talk about the
liquid vapor transition right this
classic
model of a higher level description of a
many body phenomenon where i have many
particles
and in some sense i'm missing the forest
for the trees if i look at every
position of every particle
because i realize there's some order
parameter some single number or a few
numbers
that describe a lot of what's going on
as i change the temperature and i have
tremendous predictive power
once i realize that hidden simplicity i
think one of the things that
is in some sense a psychological
i don't want to say impediment but at
least kind of uh that leads
um a little bit in a misleading
direction
in the culture of condensed matter
physics when trying to come to biology
is that
we often are looking for symmetry to
take something that looks complicated
and revealed to us
it's extremely simple but living things
are
characteristically highly unsymmetrical
and very messy and very hierarchical in
the communication between different
scales of length and energy and time
and so you don't get to just write down
a very simple beautiful theory that
realizes that only one length scale
matter only matters or what only one
energy scale matters or things
where where emergence in classic
examples and condensed matter physics
really succeeds
and the approach that i've tried to
advocate for which i think has been
somewhat successful so far we'll see and
at least you know i found it
illuminating
is to say let's take that multifarious
bundle of what life is
and try to chop it apart into a set
of distinctive lifelike behaviors so
behaviors that we think of as being
indicative of life likeness even if they
aren't unique to life
the things i would put on that list are
making copies of yourself
self-replication on the one hand
or harvesting energy from a difficult to
access
source in your environment on the other
hand or
acting in a way that embodies an
accurate prediction
of your future based on the statistics
of your past
these are each things where you might
imagine something that's not alive
but which is quite successful at doing
this activity
and which looks somewhat impressive and
if you bundle them all together it
starts to be like
oh maybe we're talking about a living
thing if it's you know it copies itself
it predicts its future
it's harvest energy you know but but at
the end of the day
we're looking through the lens of
physics life looks like
a grab bag of these specialized
behaviors
from the perspective of physics and it's
okay just to say let's treat them one by
one and start asking can i make a
physical theory of
what permits or forbids or causes the
emergence of self-replicators
can i make a physical theory of what
permits or forbids
or leads to the emergence of
self-organized prediction of the
environment
and i won't say in each case that i'm
describing the boundary between life and
non-life
but i'm certainly going to make better
sense of that in the language of physics
by engaging in that work one of the
downsides of our modern interconnected
age is a certain degradation of
privacy it's increasingly easy for bad
actors out there in the world to snoop
on what we're doing
if that's something you're concerned
about and it should be incognito mode is
not going to do it what you need is a
vpn a virtual private network
private internet access is a really
simple service that gives you a vpn
it hides your ip address from the rest
of the world so hackers
snoopers of any kind cannot listen to
you your data is encrypted so it's just
for you
private internet access is very easy to
use it's available for all platforms
including mobile platforms like ios and
android and one subscription will
protect up to 10 devices at the same
time now mindscape listeners get a
special deal if you go to
privateinternetaccess.com
mindscape there's a 30-day money-back
guarantee and by using that link you get
complete digital privacy
for less than three dollars a month with
three extra months for free
so go to private internet access dot com
slash mindscape
give yourself a little online peace of
mind
yeah actually it's interesting because i
had a stuart bartlett who is an
astrobiologist
habiogenesis researcher on the podcast
and he and michael wong have proposed a
four-part
definition of things that in that are
involved with life and basically that
you mentioned three replication
energy harvesting prediction and they
add to that some form of homeostasis
but otherwise with small changes of
vocabulary it's a very similar thing so
is that a is it a growing feeling in the
field that rather than
coming up with a once and for all
definition of the word life we can
recognize that life has different
aspects and study them individually and
then hope to put them together
i suppose i shouldn't speak for others
and speculate too much about
how popular this frame yet is
but i i certainly see
the merit of it and i i expect that it's
going to have increasing traction over
time
because it it it doesn't just kick the
can down the road but it even
i think makes a principled argument
against
trying to define life at the outset
before we can start making progress on
the science
it's very hard if you say the first step
is let's all agree on what's alive and
what isn't
and then we'll try to make a theory of
that and if instead he's going to say
well
you agree with me that living things
make copies of themselves right
you agree with me that living things to
some degree behave in ways that embody
predictions of their environment
and also you know you mentioned
homeostasis i'm not sure that word
appears in the book but there's a
characteristic of life in physical terms
that is definitely the focus of one of
the later chapters
um that essentially captures that idea
that uh
it's about how as energy flows through
this collection of matter the energy is
sort of
powering self-repair and stability and
maintenance as opposed to
causing disruption and chaotic disorder
and that's not to be taken for granted
because a lot of
driven non-equilibrium dynamics that you
could observe might look that way to you
either in reality or apparently
especially at the beginning of the flow
of energy
well yeah that leads us directly into
the next aspect that we want to bring in
which is the physics side of things
right
you're you're trying to work at the
interface of biology and
thermodynamics or non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics
where if we know one thing if people on
the street are aware of one thing
it's that entropy is increasing and
disorder is taking over so
how do you fit that aspect into what you
think about life
yeah so i i i love this discussion of
the second law and increasing entropy
because
i think that the first step in getting
into this discussion is to try to
argue for an equivalent way of talking
that is kind of ready for
a new century of non-equilibrium
statistical mechanics
um and and and and focuses the language
in the right way so
the the ways that people have talked
about entropy in the past
i think are very much born from the
early history of thermodynamics and and
what it was possible to work with
experimentally and what it was
possible to predict with that and um we
we have
you know the second law of
thermodynamics the idea that entropy is
always increasing
and so therefore there's always going to
be increasing disorder it becomes a kind
of this old chestnut where it goes out
into
popular understanding and becomes this
kind of unrigorous idea which
on the one hand conforms to our
intuition in a variety of cases because
we all know that
rooms get messy unless you kind of
invest effort in them somehow
um and and sand castles fall down etc
but at the same time we're just
confronted by a world where we
constantly see examples of things
where the internal entropy meaning the
amount of order within the system
is decreasing and so sometimes entropy
locally increases sometimes it increase
sorry sometimes it locally decreases
sometimes it locally increases
so let's just step back and instead of
talking about in those terms
let's say this whenever people talk
about entropy
what they're really talking about is
counting the number of ways something
that can happen
and that is
ultimately of interest to us as far as
predicting the world
because it has an impact on the
likelihood of certain things happening
but it is not the only factor
that determines likelihood in some kind
of probabilistic model that we're going
to make
so in the classic discussion of entropy
that you're trying to introduce the idea
to i don't know
someone in a high school chemistry class
you'd say well
suppose we count the number of ways of
collecting all the air molecules
in the corner of the room and
we also count the number of ways of
spreading all the air molecules in the
room over the whole room
clearly there are many more ways of
spreading the air over the whole room
and so it's much more likely
that the air will spread out over the
whole room so you don't have to worry
about a spontaneous vacuum just choking
you
and that's very reassuring and it seems
like what we're saying is
high entropy things are what's likely
but actually that's a specialized
scenario of a particular assumption that
we're making we're assuming
the dynamics of the molecules in the
room
have been just getting to be sort of
chaotic and explore the space of all
possible combinations and arrangements
for a long time
on some you know measure of what long
and short is in time
but of course you can take a pump and
pump all the air into a much smaller
space
if you do work on the system you're
allowed to make a vacuum
and so you're lowering the entropy of
that air um and
that's physically permissible as well so
the dynamics of a system where pumping
is going on
you're allowed to have a local decrease
um
in entropy so i think that i very much
focus
on talking about systems in this open
system frame where you say i have my
working material
and i both can think about possible
random fluctuations coming from you know
i'm at some temperature i'm in a heat
bath there are lots of things
at the molecular scale randomly banging
into me but i also have
something else outside of me that's part
of my environment that might be
doing work on me of a more organized
sort it's imparting energy to the system
that has some organization to itself
like maybe a pump or maybe
an optical stimulus or something like
that and once i'm talking in those terms
the new way of talking about this which
i think allows us to dispense to a large
degree with the discussion of entropy
at least at the outset is to say what's
the probability of
one outcome versus another outcome
that's how we should be talking about it
because then what we can notice
is that some outcomes will be likely
because they're messy
and there's more ways for them to happen
and that is the weight of entropy on the
scale
but there are other outcomes that might
be likely to happen even though they're
low entropy
but instead it's because work or other
energy exchange is really powering going
to low entropy
so we see already examples of that in
equilibrium
statistical mechanics because i can have
a low entropy outcome
called crystallization happen if i just
cool down a liquid and i
don't wonder how that works it's just
that the attractive forces between the
molecules
can overwhelm the pull so to speak of
being at higher entropy
and in this non-equilibrium world i
don't just
get to exploit attractive interactions i
also have
the possible patterning influence of
external forces that are changing over
time and pushing on me
and biasing my evolution through a space
of possible configurations
yeah i think actually i mean that's a
wonderful explanation but it's probably
even worth
elaborating on a little bit just because
i think that a lot of people
one of the things that it's hard for
outsiders who are not professional
scientists to get is sort of the lay of
the land
in terms of what ideas people think are
interesting and talk about i mean
the second law says that entropy
increases in a closed system and what
you're pointing out which is sort of
obviously true is that most systems are
open right we interact
with the rest of the world and this
whole idea that we should
we can should and can think about laws
of thermodynamics and
statistical mechanics that apply to
these open systems
is kind of new i mean it's not you know
it's something that people always knew
but the
taking it seriously aspect with things
like fluctuations theorem the arzinski
equality is a famous one i mean this is
cutting edge stuff in non-equilibrium
statement
yeah and so i think since you referred
to the
there's instillation and there's a
related result from
gavin crooks um that i think
gets explicit mentioned in the
discussion in the book um
these fluctuation theorems what what
they read what they really did
um to transform the way people think
about non-equilibrium statistical
mechanics is that i think the early
history of
non-equilibrium thinking coming from the
early to mid 20th century
was very much trying to take the
macroscopic language
of equilibrium thermodynamics that had
succeeded in the 19th century so
brilliantly
and tried to find a non-equilibrium
generalization of that and people like
onsagar and brigagine were somewhat
successful at talking about that
in the linear response regime where
you're basically close to thermal
equilibrium
but i think what was hard is that the
real success
in generalizing the ideas of stuff
statistical mechanics
wasn't going to really catch fire until
you could talk about the microscopics
and there was
i think both not as much reason to talk
about the microscopics when you couldn't
do simulations and when you could
measure much less
and also there was kind of a cultural
holdover of wanting to talk in terms of
macroscopic state variables because that
was how
equilibrium thermodynamics got going but
then what happened i think partly
or i think likely driven in part by the
emergence of a literature
of numerical simulation in the 90s
was that you started to have practical
questions you were asking just about
your simulations of stuff that was
trying to show you the microscopic
dynamics of particles
while they were at some temperature and
had some rules of how they pushed on
each other so you're
simulating physics and now you don't
just want to know the likelihood of
a state like you're asking in
equilibrium at some temperature
am i more likely to be high energy or a
low energy instead you're asking what's
the likelihood of trajectories
of a whole movie of the system and the
real
insight i think that changes how we can
talk about this uh which has been driven
by
work by uh people like gavin crooks and
and chris rossinski and others
is to talk about the relative
probabilities of trajectories like the
kirk's result
is saying if i see a movie of a driven
system and
the time reversed movie the rewind movie
how likely
relatively are these two different
movies in the dynamics that i'm
observing
and then there's a rigorous
thermodynamic result about heat exchange
with the surroundings
that tells you basically that the one
that's more likely
is the movie that puts positive amounts
of heat into the surroundings
um and then the drazinski result
uh is in a sense a special case of this
crooks result but one that really
at an earlier point several years
earlier just blew people's minds because
of what it was connecting
where it saw that the statistics
of all the different ways that you could
measure work being done in a system over
repeated experiments
could actually connect you back to
quantities that you'd be measuring
without doing work on the system uh in a
finite time but instead just doing it
really slowly in thermal equilibrium and
it was suddenly revealing to people that
there was
all of this information in the seemingly
messy and unexplainable stochastic
random uh noisiness of the
non-equilibrium setting where you're
driving the system and it does something
different every time
there was a connection back to the
language of equilibrium thermodynamics
and so if you take those results and put
them together
you can pretty easily rearrange them and
get something that looks sort of like
a jarzinski-like result that
is really derived from the crooks
relation uh that generalizes
the idea of what is the probability of a
given outcome
for your your system given that it
starts in a certain place and
and and you no longer are just saying oh
well lower energy is more likely because
that's the
right just at thermal equilibrium result
if you just have thermal fluctuations
instead you're starting to say there's
this
work history contribution there's this
question of how much work
is done every time i go from some
starting state to some ending state
and all the different ways that could
happen how much energy gets dumped into
the system
by the pattern sources in the
environment and if i collect together
the statistics of all those different
ways of doing work
there's actually information hidden
there for me about the likelihood
of one outcome over another one and now
we're talking essentially about an
evolutionary result where we can say
i think this evolutionary result uh is
more likely than that evolutionary
result
yeah and this is a perfect sort of segue
so i think that you've done this before
perhaps you've written a book about this
because you've clearly
practiced uh this sort of uh dialogue so
the idea of the the crooks and
eurozinski results in nonlinear stat
mech is
don't just say here's the average or
most likely thing
take seriously the idea there are
fluctuations around this most likely
thing and
clearly life and biology is plausibly
in that regime so how do you take this
uh sort of evolutionary picture where
you think about trajectories rather than
just states
and apply it to life which is
evolutionary in a slightly different
sense
yeah so one thing i think this is an
opportunity for me uh
to put out there is that it's helpful to
start by asking ourselves what is
distinctive and different about life
that we can't do in thermal equilibrium
so in thermal
equilibrium we're sitting at some
temperature we're getting randomly
kicked by our environment and we can
basically do
two things we can concertedly roll
downhill in energy
and that's happening because the forces
on the system are pushing it that way
that's the definition of rolling
downhill and energy
and then we can also get randomly kicked
uphill by the bombardment of
thermal fluctuations from our
environment and it's true
as i mentioned before that you can go to
orderly states in that setting you can
form a crystal for example
as long as the lowering of energy is
decisive enough in overwhelming the
tendency for the random kicks to sort of
scramble the whole arrangement of all
the building blocks in the system
however if you do that and you do it in
a way
uh where all of these building blocks
are kind of randomly diffusing around
and finding each other and sticking
together
and then once they find each other and
they're very stable what you've done is
you've made something that's going to be
extremely
hard to rearrange once it is formed
so you can make orderly structures but
they tend to be very
inert by virtue of how orderly they are
that orderliness
and inertness are they're going hand in
hand in in thermal equilibrium
but when you look at living things
what's striking about them is not that
they just seem specially ordered like
they're in some exceptionally rare
arrangement of their constituent parts
but also that they can rapidly rearrange
into such
special states but then stay in them
very stably for a long time
until they sense something else and then
they can change rapidly again so there's
this combination of
dynamism on the one hand with
stability when it's desired and order
when it's needed and you just can't buy
that
for love or money at thermal equilibrium
you need a system that
has work being dumped into it all the
time in order for that to be permitted
by basic laws that we use to describe
the physical dynamics that we observe in
these kinds of systems
so all that being said now you start to
say let me look at the characteristic
lifelike behaviors
making copies of yourself you know that
requires you to
make a copy of yourself more rapidly
than that copy falls apart
so there's a kind of arrow of time there
that you can might be you know
tickling your nose a little bit and
indeed what that means is that that has
to be powered by
irreversible dissipation you have to
absorb work from some source and then
dissipate it as heat in order to be able
to do that
similarly um with you know some kind of
energy harvesting behavior in your
system where i
changed the environment to have a
particular pattern to it and i rapidly
rearrange
things about my system to be better at
absorbing energy from that pattern for
example
but then i stay in that state for a long
time and yet i couldn't
again dynamically rearrange if i change
the pattern
that kind of dynamism is again hard to
achieve
if you're forming a crystal at
equilibrium and and indeed
in an equilibrium setting there's even
no such thing as a relationship to
a changeable pattern in the environment
because the environment in an
equilibrium system is static and is just
kind of
a constant force pushing you a certain
way so all the things when we go through
these distinctive life-like behaviors
what we find is
we have to be talking about a
non-equilibrium system and
it's maybe going to be valuable to now
have a general theoretical frame that
says
how do i write down an equation that
tells me about
what factors affect the likelihood of
outcomes in that setting
small businesses that are interested in
simplifying their operations to succeed
in today's economy
should absolutely look at as low banking
instead of the days it takes to go to a
traditional bank where you have to show
up in person
with aslo you just go to azlo.com and
apply in minutes
you get a free business checking account
with invoicing
bill pay no minimum balance requirements
and there's no waiting to use the
account with aslo's free
instant funding feature you can deposit
up to one thousand dollars and access it
instantly because you listen to this
podcast you can try aslo
pro for free for 14 days at aslo.com
mindscape the pro bundle gives you tools
like unlimited envelopes to organize
your money discounted instant transfers
and the ability to set up recurring
invoices
learn more with a free copy of aslo's
small business starter guide or just go
get started right now
get an aslo pro free 14 day trial at
aslo.com
mindscape there's no minimum deposit
required you can get started for free
right now that's spelled a z l o
dot com slash mindscape
yeah and so i i certainly buy i mean
something i talked about before also
that
there's these um extremes of super duper
order
super duper disorder which are both kind
of boring right like
they're both not a lot of interesting
room for complexity happening there
and in between is where things can
happen that are interesting and complex
including life
but that still doesn't quite address the
question of the
likelihood or inevitability of that
happening i mean
do you think we've learned anything
about when
these complex structures come to exist
and does it actually say anything about
the likelihood or inevitability of life
arising under the right circumstances
yeah i i do although i think that
i i would break that question into two
pieces because there's the question of
the likelihood of life arising and i
think whenever we say that
we immediately are thinking about this
first moment where something we want to
call life
comes onto the scene yeah and that
question as a forensic enterprise
working backward is more complicated for
a number of runes
but i think if i can start uh and i can
return to that subject but if i can
start by first saying
you know let me talk about an individual
lifelike behavior
what do i mean by talking about the
likely conditions for the emergence of a
given lifelike behavior
there i think it's easier to define the
question in physical terms
and it's also possible to in simulation
and even an experiment to start to
demonstrate
okay how does this happen how do i get
predictive control
over a process like this where i can see
it happening so to speak on a tabletop
so the example that i'll talk about to
start with but i think
it's not the most essential feature of
life or not the only one certainly
is self-organized energy harvesting so
we had a paper in physical review
letters several years ago
which uh considered a
model of a simple mechanical system
where it was just a bunch of masses and
springs
that were sort of hooking and unhooking
to each other in a random thermal bath
and so the the masses and springs are
these kind of dumb inert particles that
have the ability to entangle and
disentangle from each other
and then they form this kind of mesh of
resonator of
different random connections between
balls and springs
uh and then you can take a piece of that
and start shaking it and you can shake
it at a particular frequency for example
so if you didn't shake it you would just
get thermal equilibrium you just get
some
random mess of balls hooking and
unhooking from each other with springs
that would be determined just by the
energies of the states eventually if you
reach thermal equilibrium
but once you start shaking part of the
system and you choose for example a
particular frequency
now you have energy flowing in from
the forcing that you're giving to the
system but the flow of that energy
through the system
is going to impact its evolution it's
going to impact the exploration
of this high dimensional space of
possible combinations
of a bunch of simple building blocks and
with very simple roles for interaction
among these different mechanical pieces
you can get a situation where you pick a
frequency you wiggle
part of the system at that frequency and
then what you end up seeing before too
long
is a particular evolutionary outcome not
a single microscopic arrangement
but a family of possible outcomes that
have a specialized ability
to absorb more energy from that
particular frequency
and so in the same way that i might
imagine
if i need to be able as a living thing
to
fly i'm gonna probably have to have
wings of some kind but there are ways of
doing that that a bird does it or
there's a way of doing it that a fly
does it and they're not the same
similarly there are aspects of this that
have a kind of a
flavor of physical adaptation because
the individual structure i see at the
end of this process
will always be unique because the space
of possible things to explore in
combinations is so vast
that if i do the same experiment over
again i'll never get the same result
but the commonality they have is that
they
all can absorb energy much better from
the environment that they're in
in a way that's finely matched to some
characteristic of that environment like
a frequency that it's being
is being used to force the system they
can all absorb energy much better
than a random arrangement of their
constituent parts and so
i would point to that as a hallmark of
something that looks like a form
function relationship
in biology we take function for granted
as it helps you to survive and reproduce
and in physics we don't get function a
priori because it's just
stuff flying around and banging into
each other but what you at least can
recognize
in this kind of a system is
exceptionality of the outcome
in its physical relationship to into its
environment there's a fine-tuned sense
in which this is a highly non-random
arrangement of many constituent parts
that has an exceptional ability with
regard to energy flow from the
environment
yeah i mean i guess there's a i'm almost
there with you i mean i think i'm
totally there with you on the whole
big picture but there's a bit of
intuition that i've struggled to develop
and not quite succeeded here when
people say that in a closed system
entropy increases and why well
entropy corresponds to the number of
ways you can arrange the system so that
it looks
the same so there are more ways to be
high entropy than to be low entropy
that makes sense to me and now you're
saying that certain
uh arrangements of little subsystems
have a better ability to
absorb energy other people have said you
know certain
complex catalyzed reactions will
increase
the entropy production rate faster but
i'm missing a bit of intuition as to why
i should care
about that like what is the rule that
says i should absorb energy as fast as
possible
well in fact and this is a very
important point
there is no such rule because it is
still
a system specific property in the sense
that
sometimes you can get feedback that
leads to what looks like an energy
harvesting behavior that self-organizes
and it has to do with so to speak the
particular chemical rules or physical
rules for how the pieces of a system
interact
like what kinds of springs are tangling
with each other
and then you can also devise a system
which we've studied as well
and there's a more recent paper we have
about this where you get the opposite
kind of immersion fine tuning so you can
also have
self-organized fine-tuned being bad at
absorbing energy from a particular
environment
and when we hear that at first we don't
think that we're talking about a living
thing
because we think oh living things need
to eat and they're good at that
but i think that actual outcome is much
more linked to
the sort of homeostasis aspect of life
and i can unpack that a little bit yeah
um further down the line um but just
before diving into into the details of
that example
um i think the other thing that i've
still left missing
and what i've described so far is i've
been telling you about examples
that are empirical that we've studied in
simulation where it does something
but the question is what is the insight
that allows you to say
i can predict generally in this class of
systems which way things are going to go
and i i start to be able to know what to
expect
and and why does it happen this way and
i think that the way to understand it
uh is this that if i have a combination
of a bunch of different building blocks
i can think of some combination of them
as being like the location of a ball
in a landscape in a mountain range where
my height in that
landscape is my energy so
it's very close to the real intuition
that you'd have
for an actual ball in an actual mountain
range except for the fact
that you have many more dimensions than
three you have lots of dimensions
because you have lots of particles that
you're assembling together
and so to summarize the location to use
the location of a ball
to summarize the configuration of 10 to
the 23rd particles or whatever you need
a very conventional
landscape that they're exploring so if i
don't have an external environment that
pushes on me with some pattern forcing
then all i can really do as i said
before is roll downhill and
get kicked randomly back uphill and then
after a time i'll tend to go downhill
and stay downhill
unless there really are just many more
ways of randomly staying uphill
so it's just a classic tradeoff between
low energy and high entropy
but if i now start pushing on the system
with an external source of work the way
i should think about how this game
changes
is now i it's like i've put ski lifts or
escalators
in this landscape and there are
particular configurations i can be in
where the way they absorb energy from
the environment is going to have an
impact
on how much they can get lifted up some
mountainside and drop down the other
why is that important that's important
because if you are
lifted up a very tall mountain and then
you fall down the other side but there's
no ski lift on the other side or there's
no escalator on the other side
then you're stuck you can't go back the
way that you came
and the more that statistical
irreversibility
ends up being felt in the evolution of
the system the more it's the case that
the most
indelible marks the most irreversible
changes in how the system
you know in a biased way explores the
space of possible shapes
accumulates over time those are going to
be the result
of having been in shapes that happened
to be good at absorbing energy from the
particular environment
so it's still going to break into cases
whether that leads you to an outcome
that ends up being exceptionally bad at
absorbing energy or an outcome that
leads to you know being exceptionally
good at absorbing energy because it has
to do with the shape of the landscape
and the pattern of forcing so you can
get into the details of how it breaks
out into those cases
but the unifying idea which i've called
dissipative adaptation
and some things i've written about this
is that you think about
the outcome structure the outcome
combination of building blocks in your
system
as being the result of a biased
exploration of the space
of possibilities where the history of
moments in its past when it
absorbed energy from the environment in
a way that
involves some kind of matching between
its structure and the pattern of the
environment
that the accumulated effect of those
moments ends up being
a signature you see in the structure you
end up getting knocked into
by this whole process so you know i
guess
zooming just back out to the point
you're making about entropy
i think the key thing here is that uh
being in a low entropy configuration
i could be in this kind of a scenario
in a high energy and highly dynamic
sub portion of this mountain range or
this landscape
as long as the pattern of the way the
system is being driven just can't kick
me out
of this very strange
kind of uh plateau or mesa or what have
you in this landscape
you know it it it previously would have
been the case that randomly kicks would
eventually always knock me down hill
uh if there was far enough to fall that
i could really go to lower energy
but what's so impressive to us in
general with a lot of things living
things are doing
is that because there's a pattern input
of some kind
they can be knocked uphill into these
low entropy arrangements that are
trapped in some high mountain pass that
has a special shape
that's matched to the way the system is
being pushed on but it does sound like
maybe i'm
reading too much into this that um
there's a slightly deflationary
answer here to my original question in
the sense that
uh sometimes structures like this will
form
sometimes they won't and it might be
hard or impossible to get a general
principle that is
that is uh applicable over all kinds of
systems rather than
looking at it at a more fine-grained
level
well i think that what we need to think
about
is if you look at real life that we know
and how what makes it tick
um part of what always is intimidating
to theoretical physicists when trying to
say how am i gonna explain how something
like this comes into being
is how messy it feels that there are
many length scales
many time skills many energy scales that
are involved
and part of the reason that that's there
is because that reflects
this tremendous combinatorial diversity
of the particular physical chemical
interactions that are possible
in the working material that we're
working with so i have
in a living thing carbon nitrogen oxygen
sulfur phosphorus you know
various other kinds of atoms in in lower
trace amounts et cetera
and those have particular ways they can
combine
that are tremendously verse they're
tremendously diverse in the kinds of
properties they can have
if i devised for you instead an
experiment where i said
all you have is i don't know um xenon
you know just xenon and and you have to
make everything that you're going to
make out of combinations of xenon atoms
it might be really hard and it might be
it might so happen to be
that at least on the time scale you're
willing to wait or given the energy
skills you're willing to make use of
that there aren't really a lot of ways
of putting xenon atoms together
that are going to be qualitatively
different in how they respond
to inputs from the environment so i
i will you know happily admit that
an essential thing in understanding
life likeness is that in order for it to
be really striking there needs to be
novelty through combination coming from
how building blocks can be put together
in different ways so that they really
are quite distinct in how they react to
the same environment
and there are physical scenarios you can
devise
where maybe the effective chemical
diversity or whatever you want to call
it the effective
knobbliness and distinctiveness of that
whole energy landscape and
all the different corners of it being
different is just not different enough
you don't have enough books out of that
library
to choose from that you're going to be
impressed by what the non-equilibrium
driving gets you at the end
and and the last thing i'll say is that
the other aspect of this
is that it may be that the way you're
driving the system
doesn't yet have enough of a distinctive
pattern because if you're not driving
the system with a pattern that has
enough of a barcode to it that has
enough of a particular structure to it
you may also be at a loss to recognize
what it means to be finely tuned to that
right so if the only thing i'm doing for
example
is heating one side of the system and
cooling the other side of a system
it is a non-equilibrium system and i can
get kind of cool looking whirls that
emerge in a fluid as a result of doing
that
but how many numbers did i need to use
to describe that non-equilibrium driving
such that i now could say oh look at the
state the system's in it's extremely
finely tuned to my choice of how i'm
driving the system
in a way where random rearrangements of
all of these molecules in the fluid
would look dramatically ill-suited to
doing whatever it is that this
particular
set of convection cells is doing i
actually haven't studied the rayleigh
bernard system that i'm referring to
very much
and so i don't want to rule out the
possibility that some kind of
fine tuning could be recognized there
but i do think
it's a choice about not only the
potential for novel combinations in the
working material
but also the complexity of the
statistics
of the external environment that would
allow us to say
wow this is really well adapted because
the higher dimensional the complexity is
of that environment the more we'll be
able to recognize an exceptional
relationship
does this kind of reasoning have
implications for things like the
anthropic principle for the fine-tuning
of the laws of nature
where do you come down on thinking that
if the constants in the standard model
have been very different life would be
impossible
um so i i usually try not to
to rush to make declarations like that
because i do think sometimes
through kinds of physical emergence that
we're aware of you can sometimes get
things at higher scales that don't seem
built into
the simple interaction so for example i
could have a fluid
that is just made of one kind of
particle and if i just look at the
behavior of that fluid
um in in a very kind of naive
equilibrium statmex sort of way it kind
of looks like there's only one energy
scale for how the particles interact and
i can't really like make a hand that
grabs onto something because
whatever it grabs onto it will just fuse
with and so you can't build interesting
things out of one energy scale
but then of course if it becomes a fluid
that's in the turbulent regime and i
have all this hierarchy of scales of
energy cascades between different scales
um if it starts to be that if i look at
emergent levels of organization the
fluid
perhaps i shouldn't rule out the
possibility that something can be
happening there
that it's as though i got a new
chemistry
uh at a higher scale as an emergent
property
of something that had very unappealing
chemical simplicity at some shorter
scale
so as a physicist i want to be very
naive and cautious both about that and
also about
what it means to consider the
stochastic process of choosing physical
constants because you need a model of
how universes are made in order for that
to make sense
and and that's um certainly not
something i
should claim to be expert in um and also
something i think
has a fundamental philosophical
challenge kind of hiding in the
background but
you know that being said i do think um
i could imagine the situation where at
least if we're talking
more practically and we're saying we're
going to fly around and look at
planets and try to see which ones we
should be expecting to find life in
well while it may be true that you don't
necessarily need exactly what we have
here
to make you know something like what we
are
in life it might also be that
if we found a planet that was monoatomic
in its composition and just made of
xenon or something that i'd say let's
look somewhere else first
if we have to choose because that that
sounds to me like
the diverse space possible combinations
could just be more limiting
i think i'm going to get angry comments
on youtube from people from the xenon
planet here
that we're disrespecting them but i
didn't want to i want to not
skip over something you mentioned and
maybe didn't quite complete this idea of
um not just life coming into existence
but it's
maintenance it's metabolism uh
homeostasis
there are lessons there i i want to make
sure that you had a chance to say what
you wanted to say
yeah yeah absolutely so uh we we talked
a little bit about an example of a
system that has a self-organized
ability to absorb more energy from an
environmental pattern
and i think that we always are looking
for that in life because
all examples of life we know are
self-replicators and self-replicators do
need to eat and so getting better
at getting access to food is always one
of the things for darwinian reasons that
we expect to see that
um in living things that we know but
there's another thing living things do
which i would argue is an equally
impressive
fine-tuned self-organized life-like
behavior
or rather excuse me i should say
it is an equally impressive lifelike
behavior
whose self-organization is worth
studying and that's how you get
something
that you might want to call self-repair
or homeostasis
um that has i also a highly adapted
relationship to a given environment
so what do i mean by that well think
about a living thing in the following
way
it's true that in order to live i need
energy input right i need to eat
but it's not true that i'm equally eager
to gain access for that purpose to all
sources of energy right
i can't just say instead of a sandwich
today i'm going to get an equivalent
dose in joules
of gamma radiation or tnt or whatever
that doesn't work because
actually most arbitrarily chosen ways of
putting energy into a system
are going to be like a bull in a china
shop energy is just
motion or the potential for motion if
you're talking in newtonian terms
and that's really the relevant intuition
for this discussion if i dump energy
into a system
and just give it to parts of the system
in no particular way
i'm going to be activating a bunch of
different random rearrangements
in different parts and in a living thing
we call that damage
so that's why swallowing a stick of
dynamite or
getting ghost with radiation or whatever
is generally thought of as being not
conducive to health
because living things are in a very
small corner of their possible
configuration space right they're
highly non-random especially you know
especially
exceptional combinations of their
constituent parts
and if you start doing the more random
exploration
uh of the space of possibilities there
you're going to stop being a frog or
you're going to stop being a person
and start being a pile of carbon
nitrogen and oxygen etc with no
particular provenance so you don't want
to do that
and now when you look at the living
thing
what's remarkable from that perspective
is there is a way of delivering energy
into the system
that doesn't have this effect by and
large right that as energy flows through
it isn't a bull in a china shop that if
i get it from the right kind of source a
source with the right pattern which in
the case of people
is energy in the form of chemical bonds
of certain kinds
in the food that we eat in the case of
plants it's a spectrum of photons of
certain colors
then you're okay and you can take that
and use it to spin all the water wheels
and suddenly
the energy flow is conducive to health
and you're using it to
fix yourself and maintain yourself in
this
specially chosen high mountain pass in
the landscape of possibilities
where if you didn't have this
energy source constantly kicking you
uphill in the right direction
you'd fall down and die you'd you'd roll
down towards thermal equilibrium and
eventually fall to pieces enough that
you wouldn't be alive anymore
if we're talking about things in those
terms now we have a very good
mechanistic understanding of how you can
self-organize that kind of relationship
to a patterned environment
if you have a collection of particles
that are in some landscape
of possibilities with different energies
and there's this disorder of
interactions between them that gives a
kind of
effective chemical diversity to how
these different pieces combine
and you start for example beaming
a stimulus of a certain frequency into
the system so that's like
light of a certain color or a song of a
certain pitch
and then you watch how the system jumps
around while it's exploring its base of
possibilities
what you see and this is in a paper that
we've just resubmitted but it's already
on the archive of the lead author is dr
radish kedia
um and also another paper in the archive
um
by a graduate student uh
at mit new jacob gold where we were
looking at different kinds of systems
like this
if you have a
patterned input such as a particular
frequency and you take a
disordered set of interacting pieces
that have lots of different
possible ways of liking to move with the
environment depending on what corner of
their configuration space they're
currently stuck in then in the short
term you absorb a lot of energy
the system jumps around it rearranges it
changes its shape
and in the longer term it learns how to
absorb less energy from that environment
and it fine tunes away from high energy
absorption
it finds a state which is still an
excited state that's at higher energy
than what you get
at the equilibrium temperature that
you're you know subjecting the system to
it's still an excited state but it's a
state that somehow
in the way that its motions are being
excited by the energy flow
just stays in this low dimensional
correlated object that's coordinating
the motion of all these different
particles together
such that they stay matched to the
particular pattern
of the source and then if you change the
pattern of that forcing
you could change the frequency you could
change things about the directions of
which parts of the system are getting
poked and pushed
in different ways then you see again
this transient rearrangement and things
get scrambled so it's like you've
switched from
plants that live off of x-rays to plants
that live off of gamma rays or what have
you
um and now suddenly everything gets
blown to smithereens and you rearrange
you find a new quieting state and now
again you're in this excited state
that looks like it's using the energy
that it's absorbing to maintain itself
in a matched way to the pattern of that
particular source
a lot of people a lot of scientists when
they see the kinds of things you're
talking about right where
you can dig into something as
manifestly inscrutable and and ineffable
as the
meaning of life the meaning of the word
life not what why we're here but
they'll say that oh look we're on the
road to just explaining
all this stuff on purely naturalistic
purely physicalistic terms you've
already alluded to the fact that a lot
of people will do that and that
you do not want to do that you want to
swim against the tide a little bit here
i will confess i think that most of my
listeners already know that
i totally do that i wrote a whole book
the big picture on how
naturalism is good enough for explaining
uh the world as far as we can tell even
though there's a lot it hasn't done
yet you want to uh put in an alternative
perspective so
i don't want to put any words into your
mouth because i know this is an easy
thing to get
wrong to caricature into straw man so
tell us in your own words how you think
about this relationship
between religious ideas and scientific
ones
sure so um i guess
you know one way of putting it is to say
when i decided
to write this book i had
an awareness that this part of the
discussion
was always a potential way things could
roll once you put a bunch of ideas out
there
and so i didn't want to seem naive about
that and i didn't want to
start just only focusing on the
scientific discussion without
in a sense weighing in and saying and
here's the wrapping in the broader
context in which i want to put that
and i i think because of that i thought
okay well so i have a personal direction
i'm coming from
um i in adulthood after growing up as a
physicist uh
started studying the torah a lot and
being very interested in
uh being a jew and and i actually
ultimately studied to become an orthodox
rabbi
and i am interested in that perspective
on
the world and the human condition and it
informs a lot of how i think about
what i'm doing and why and so that is
my way of being comfortable engaging in
the philosophical discussion and so i
thought okay
so i'll go and look in the sources that
i am committed to
finding authority in and and studying
the world through that lens and i'll see
what i see
and i think what ended up coming out in
in the form that the book took
was that on the one hand i was kind of
delighted and
i guess somewhat surprised to find
uh part of the hebrew bible that really
seemed very
interested specifically in contemplating
the boundary between life and non-life
in material terms and
not doing that obviously in the language
of modern physics
but doing it more in the language of the
everyday experience of how
people how human beings experience the
material world
um as a bunch of different natural
phenomena
things like water coursing through
sediment and producing branch structures
or the formation of snowflakes
or um the
way in which we can ourselves appreciate
without being scientists so to speak
that our bodies are made of stuff that
once it
breaks off of us starts to seem sort of
more like inanimate inert
dead matter like the dust under our feet
and
when a human being confronts that there
is the question of all right what what
kind of contemplation does that
dispose us to and i think one thing that
i try to treat at the end of the book is
one kind of comment about how this makes
us feel
as experiencers of the human condition
but i think if someone even is not
interested in that aspect of it and
they're not necessarily coming to the
book with any
interest per se in what the bible has to
say about anything
i think what i also turned out to me to
be exciting
and ultimately i felt valuable
pedagogically
is that because the hebrew bible
addresses itself
to the unfiltered experience of the
individual human being
not through microscopes not through
telescopes but in this very kind of
tangible
everyday sense what does the world seem
to be like
from the perspective of a person that
its contemplation
of this topic ends up being expressed
in terms of things that are very
tangible and relatable and as a result
you have these kind of conceptual
talismans where you say all right how am
i gonna
explain what a non-equilibrium system
exploring a space of possible
combinations
with an external drive is like for
someone in terms that feel very broadly
accessible
to everyday human experience well for
example when moses
is given a sign by god of taking the the
water of the nile river
and pouring it on the dry ground and it
becomes blood
that sounds like a parlor trick to a
certain kind of ear
but if you take it more seriously as
knowing about what the world is and say
what kind of point could be
hiding there if we assume in a sense
that the text knows
how the world works and is not dumber
than me about that but maybe smarter
than me
then what you start to realize is this
is a very
compact metaphorical discussion
of what it is for a non-equilibrium
system to explore a space of possible
combinations because
dust of the earth is the essence of
particulate matter that can be stuck
together
and in different ways and even dust
mixed with water
gives you different kinds of mud with
different qualitative properties just
depending on
the kind of dust and the ratio of dust
to water etc
so you have all these ideas of
qualitative emergence and novelty
through combination
and it's also horrifically river water
that the texas is talking about and not
just water
and river water is water that flows and
it's water that carries energy as well
as mass flow and as a result we even see
in the world complex emergence of branch
structures you know if you watch water
roll for sediment
you can see the emergence of complex
branching that reminds one of veins in a
leaf or
in even you know your own body and it's
not exactly the same process but it's
evocative of much of the same physics
that we end up wanting to talk about
which is how energy flow can cause
particular
specialized vapes to emerge in space of
combinations that are being explored
by a bunch of different particles that
can clump together in different ways
so i i think ultimately what i've what i
hope
i've achieved in the book is if someone
comes to it
only being interested in learning about
the physics i actually hope that the
use of the frame of biblical narrative
that the chapters are sort of wrapped in
um
magnifies their understanding of the
physics by giving them
tangible equivalence in the everyday
world that they can latch on to
and at the same time also i think some
people are
given to contemplation of the human
condition
in ways that certainly extend beyond the
purview of science
and if they're interested in that
discussion then there's a
treatment of that subject coming from my
own perspective
and certainly it's going to express the
particular ways that
i prefer to grapple with these kinds of
questions but
um hopefully it's interesting
nonetheless yeah i mean even in my
super atheist book the big picture i
tried to make the point that look it
would be crazy to think
that there was nothing of value to be
found
in religious scriptures or traditions
for thousands of years
the most careful thinking about the
human condition was done in the context
of those
conditions of those traditions but it's
a little bit different
to talk about scientific questions
versus sort of
uh finding purpose and meaning of life
questions would you just be super clear
to the audience
would you want to say that the hebrew
bible literally anticipated
ideas that we're now thinking of or can
be used to illuminate them by thinking
about them in more metaphorical ways
well i think that i would want to be
careful about talking about anticipation
in in describing what that could mean
because i don't
want to advocate for relating to
the text of the hebrew bible as saying
well because this is
revelation from the hand of the world's
creator it actually
secretly and esoterically is a science
textbook
if we just decode it in the right way i
think that
there's a long discussion about why
that's not going to be a successful
enterprise as a kind of methodology for
reading the text
um and there's i think religious
arguments against relating the text that
way
at least from the perspective that i'm
coming from um
but that being said i think that this
topic has a particular kind of
accessibility in that regard because
there are some things where you know if
we're going to talk about
how the wave particle
duality discovered in quantum theory
uh is going to impact our understanding
of
how it is that certain optical
properties of certain materials we see
in everyday experience um are actually
brought about uh you're you're more
working in a regime where talking about
anticipation
i don't know i'm not really digging in
in that place because
i'm not even sure what in everyday
experience allows us to talk about
i don't know that the spectrum of the
hydrogen atom or something like that
but i think what's different here a bit
you know in comparison to a lot of other
things that you can study carefully in
physics you know
gravitational waves with ligo or
whatever uh
is that we're talking about something
that there is a lot of empirical
knowledge of that is quite qualitative
so
while it's true that we don't by being
material beings living in a material
world we don't learn
statistical mechanics by default
you know quite the contrary at the same
time we do know a lot about what it's
like to be alive
and we have a lot of qualitative
experience of many of the
material processes that are relevant to
non-equilibrium dynamics that helps us
to understand what i think is
important to the physics of life
likeness so you know
the the by way of contrast
in order to seek quantum effects
genuinely quantum effects you usually
need
a a particularly specialized apparatus
that allows you to get to some low
temperature
or allows you to you know deal with
single electrons being spat out of an
oven or single photons that are coming
through some
um source are
coming out of some source but if you're
talking about um
genuinely far from thermal equilibrium
instances of self-organization that
recapitulate some aspect of life
likeness
that isn't so hard to come by uh as
you're out for a walk so to speak you
know you could
trip over while out for a walk a
hillside where
uh a flood that was caused by rainfall
led to some kind of
alluvial branching of of sediment that
was being deposited on
you know i've seen this in like a
parking lot or something once and and
and that does provoke unicon inflation
and it and it does
it's not irrelevant to the actual
physics that you should be
bringing to bear when trying to think
about uh what's going on
um in life even once we get fancier with
how we describe the physics at a
molecular level so
since we're working very much in the
classical regime
where the intuitions of watching a ball
bearing fall through honey are not
irrelevant to talking about what it's
like for a protein to change shape
um in a viscous fluid like water
at la reynolds number you know these
things have
conceptual relationship to each other so
all that being said i think what that
means
is that even if we're just talking about
things that the human experience can
know by intuition from contemplating
the question of what it is for life to
be built out of materials
which is something that we can see by
sort of
looking at how lifeless a fingernail is
once it falls off of the body
we get the opportunity perhaps in
the wisdom of humankind to you know
develop understanding of what some of
these relationships might
correspond to in you know out in the
world that we observe and you don't only
see this in the hebrew bible you see it
in other
ancient traditions as well um
and and also i think there's a
fundamental question of adjudicating
anticipation
versus you know appeal to um
intuition of the interpreter is really a
very hard thing to
define precisely because when we're
interpreting text
we always bring what we know about the
world into that interpretation
and it can be hard to really control
what comes out
of the interpretation and define what we
injected and what we discovered
i mean maybe you can elaborate on
one of the points you just made i mean
there are plenty of people who will be
listening to this
and uh some will be sympathetic to the
general idea but they won't be in a
jewish tradition they'll be in something
else do you think there's something
special about the hebrew bible or do you
think this there's sort of a methodology
whereby by looking at ancient
texts of wisdom we can illuminate ways
that we're thinking about the modern
scientific age
um the way that i would put it is
certainly the reason that i'm working
from that text
is because i have commitments to
that text's perspective on the world
that make it
the one where i feel kind of um
obligated to to work from if i'm trying
to engage with some of the kinds of
questions
that go beyond the scope of um the
narrow
scientific description um and and so
i i didn't sort of start with a list of
different religious traditions and say
which one is going to be best for
explaining non-equilibrium physics
i'm very happy to admit i bring my
personal you know commitments and
motivations into that aspect of the
discussion
um and i also don't want to
argue um that i
i know for certain that if we're going
to kind of lop off
just a piece of a given ancient
tradition and say
what might it be contemplating that is
somewhat universal to the human
experience
that there might be a lot of overlap or
parallelism that we could establish and
and you can do this in all sorts of ways
not only in ways that you know pertain
to
um to physics so i i wouldn't discourage
anyone from
you know looking somewhere else and
seeing what they find there if that's
what's interesting to them
um but it was kind of a an enterprise of
interpretation that
you know this is what i had the kind of
knowledge and skill for and so it's
where i was looking
and i i guess i ultimately think also
there may be something that is um
particularly interesting
about the tradition of the hebrew bible
in regard to this because
of its vehement monotheism at least in
the sense that um
the the desire to explain different
aspects of the world
as the result of different interacting
personalities
in more polytheistic descriptions
probably makes it less likely
that uh you end up thinking of the world
as a whole
fabric that has kind of a set of rules
that one
person decided um through which you can
start to understand it because
um it may be more likely to represent
the world as kind of a
quixotic combination of different
inscrutable personalities
um in that case but you know i i
i think that certainly widens the field
beyond what i feel
competent to comment on yeah i mean do
you think uh
this is going a little bit what we're
talking about here but
do you think that there are just sort of
principled philosophical
reasons to think that a purely
scientific naturalist
description of the world falls short in
terms of a complete explanation
um i mean do you think that people who
are uh
scientifically naturalistically inclined
are
uh cheating by not offering answers to
questions like maybe
why there is a universe at all or
something like that or is that not the
kind of
road you go down so i you know
in one sense this is a question that i'd
love to write a whole other book about
at some point
and i think it's very interesting and a
lengthy discussion and so i i don't want
to claim to be able to do
justice to it here and you know i i do
um i do think it should be said
that um one
respect in which i was trying to
in a sense avoid that discussion in this
particular book
was that i on the one hand
do want to show people by example that i
can be a person
who addresses both
the biblical text and yeah the physical
science
without compromising an intellectual
honesty or without compromising
on you know how uh
methodologically it is coherent to
approach either enterprise
and i don't see a conflict between them
so i try by example to demonstrate
here's a way you can talk about both of
these things at the same time and not
see them at loggerheads
and maybe that should be a starting
point for a discussion about whether
there really is such a
fundamental line of scrimmage here or
immiscibility here
but i don't for the for the most part in
the book take up the subject itself
of you know religion and science and and
whether there is
um whether there should be a
a sort of winner take all conflict uh
between these two
um views of the world um
and and i i so i i it's a discussion i'm
very interested in but it's not
the subject of the book because i wanted
the book to mainly be about explaining
the physics and also just kind of by
example putting it in a wrapping that
shows
you can have a a broader context for
this understanding that
um situates you respectfully within
um the tradition that i'm coming from um
but but all that being said
i i do think that
um with regard more specifically to the
question that you're asking
there are a few things that i could just
say to hint at where i would
take this whole discussion if i were
trying to start another book one of them
is
that i think there are different things
that we can try to say about the world
that are arguably true or where
you know they can be taken to be true as
a
compact among people who uh are gonna
work towards some ideal of truth with
the shared method and i think science is
one such compact but it's not the only
one
and when viewed in those terms is get
back to gets back to what we were
talking about
as biology and physics being different
languages i also think
that in some sense the whole enterprise
of the natural sciences
is kind of like a black and white camera
that you could use if you want to
photograph a rainbow right that
you're going to get a representation of
the system and it will in some sense
in the forms of representation it's
capable of it will be accurate
but the question is whether you take it
to be totalizing and complete
or whether you admit that its
methodology
and its assumptions kind of
automatically
focus it or or limited in what it seeks
to capture and what it deliberately
ignores
so the thing that i point to in the
sciences is that
the methodology of science strains
towards the ideal of objectivity
so if i discover something it's not a
scientific discovery really
until i can describe it to other
scientists and convince them
of the coherence of my argument and my
interpretation of data
and that they can do the same
experiments and get the same results and
so
it's a social community that builds
itself around the idea
that we strain towards what can be made
objective
um and that's very powerful and it
captures a lot about what's true about
the world
but i'm not willing immediately to dive
headlong into
uh the kind of additional
axiomatic claim that there is no such
thing as truth that is
not objective or at least that can be
eventually rendered objective um and and
in some sense i do think a lot of times
people can be very educated as
scientists without having been asked
to engage deeply with that issue and and
ask themselves
what happens when you start you know
really rolling it all back
and questioning which assumptions you're
making to get to go
about how you define what you mean to
have come convincingly to
a a convincing proposition um
so that's that's one thing you know i'll
let you respond but i could
ramble on at length no actually i think
uh you've done too good a job
at bringing us to a perfect uh ending
point because i mean i think
it brings us full circle into this idea
that
one of the things that scientists at
least some sign not all scientists we
all know scientists who we'd rather have
just stay in their laboratories but
uh as a field it does seem to me to be
important
that we engage with these broader
questions whatever our specific answers
might be the idea that we'll we'll have
different answers different ways of
approaching
connecting scientific knowledge of the
world to the broader human questions but
acknowledging that the questions exist
and might have a relationship between
each other is the first step
yeah no i i think i would agree with
that and i think that's the jumping off
point
for the right discussion and if if i'm
trying to kind of
say something additional about this
wearing my hat as a physicist a bit more
i think the other thing that we have to
just admit is that
there's a lot that goes into physical
models that are very powerful and
effective
where we're nonetheless making
assumptions that are useful
but not necessarily justified other than
for their simplicity or their beauty or
that they get us as far as we wanted in
terms of predicting what we wanted
for example the assumption we make when
dealing with a heat bath
that the spectrum of noise that you get
from the heat bath has
a certain simple form um you know you
could relate this to the idea of all
right i'm looking at the air in the room
that i'm in right now
and i'm not worried about whether it's
going to all collect in one corner
and that's because i hiding in the
background have this naive assumption
that the initial condition
wasn't specially chosen but of course
you could specially choose the initial
condition
of a bunch of molecules of fluid so that
they're about to collect in the corner
in about 10 minutes and that
would actually be an extremely
exceptional initial condition
that by many measures that we could
generate would look random for a long
time
uh and so you know machine learning is
an interesting thing to bring in here
you know because it's all about finding
kind of hidden on randomness and high
dimensional data
but i think something we have to admit
to ourselves is that
there's uh a bias at the outset in the
kind of
theories we construct where we found
them on notions of
simple unbiased randomness because that
does well enough for us in predicting
the experiments that we do
but we haven't really proven that's the
order of the universe we've just
found it's a useful enough assumption
for doing certain things
yeah i mean it's a great uh you put a
lot of big ideas here on the table and
it you're certainly convincing convince
me that there's uh
room for a lot of tremendous discoveries
in in the years to come so jeremy lin
thanks so much for being on the
windscape podcast
thanks a lot john i really enjoyed it
[Music]
you